speaking of leikov and johnson
you mentioned well it's in your book a
couple quotes from them one is that
reason doesn't separate us from the
animals but instead puts us on a
continuum with it because
we're in well reason is
predicated an embodiment now i'm
wondering if you can explain that
because reason to me has to do with
logical inference and so on like if then
statements how is an if then statement
related to my body per se
well i think the problem might be in
thinking too literalistically about what
your body is
um
i mean it might not be as it were in
your thumb i agree
but
your body is everything that is you
apart from
well not apart from anything really i
mean
we are
for the time that we are alive on this
earth
what our bodies make us
and animals that
don't have language and don't apparently
have
any kind of schema of logic can solve
logical puzzles they can reason things
you know crows
and magpies can
give
correct answers to logical problems as
an eight or nine year old human being
won't
i mean that's just one example but i
mean the more one
reads about animals and even insects the
more one realizes that the concept that
only we can act reasonably or rationally
is wrong
you've probably seen on youtube there is
in fact uh
um
a filmed
episode of a crow solving an eight-step
logical puzzle
and although it has solved each step of
the puzzle
in isolation before it has never solved
this particular sequence and in a matter
of about three minutes or five minutes
it's not a very long clip it has
actually taken the eight steps that will
allow it to secure the food that it's
after now i mean that's in itself what
do you say about that you know is it the
crow's language is it's it's mathematics
or what somehow from experience
and our bodies are the repositories of
all our experience that is that is
solving this problem
and we don't solve half as many things
as we think by thinking about them
in fact nine tenths of all the great
decisions we make are done unconsciously
we arrive at them unconsciously after
thinking about other things sleeping and
then saying i think i'll do that
and when we are not aware of things as
julian james first did out to me anyway
in his 1976 book um the origins of
consciousness in the breakdown of the
bicameral mind
we don't really need consciousness for
very much we can
weigh options form judgments solve
puzzles evaluate beauty fall in love
and do many many things without thinking
about them
at some level we are working on them but
that
what the left hemisphere privileges as
thinking
is just the left hemispheres kind of
thinking which is explicit in language
and foregrounding whatever is in the
mind but there's a whole
what we're conscious of is
only one percent maximum of all that
there is that's going on in our minds
so the idea that you know we have to be
conscious
and reason in order to think cleverly is
wrong i mean my one of my favorite
philosophers is a.n whitehead and
in the book in
fact on the structure of mathematics he
said
um
i can't remember the exact phrase which
is wonderful but he says that
conscious
is like cavalry charges in battle
it's expensive
it's wasteful it requires fresh horses
and can only be done at unusual moments
so most of the time we're we're living
perfectly rationally perfectly
intelligently but without actually
thinking about things explicitly